[Musique]
et
je vais avoir bilan
il habite dans une maison vraiment pas
comme les autres
c'est les aigles pêcheurs
sa dosette par la
billy là il n'a pas de téléphone n'ya
pas d'internet et je lui ai écrit une
lettre il ya quelques mois il ya un mois
à prima j'ai reçu ça
ça c'est mignon et quand on voit une
lettre comme ça on a envie de venir
built operate
là on est au fin fond de l'état du maine
aux états unis je suis venu voir où et
comment habitent les américains qui ont
choisi de vivre autrement pas comme les
autres je vous propose une exploration
de l'habitat expérimentale du nouveau
monde
il ya deux sentiers là mais
tiens regarde ça c'est
ça c'est le signe celle-ci de bilan
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
la regarde
ah ouais mais c'est litres et je n'ai
pas vu j'avais pas
des petits panneaux solaires peut être
qu'il est en train de faire la sieste il
dessine cellule à la haye il est là sur
son bureau
c'est incroyable ça tu as l'air brian
maison dirait une pagode atteint le toit
est tout
[Musique]
il y a deux manières de venir voir la
maison de bill cowperthwaite 1h30 de
marche à travers la forêt ou une heure
de canoë dans les fjords de l'atlantique
et à ce
jour bill ça c'est bon de te rencontrer
t'inquiète pas pour les chaussures
j'ai vu une photo de sa maison il ya
vingt ans dans un bouquin et déjà
j'avais flashé
j'adore cet endroit
il passé impressionnant
la plupart des maisons ont des poutres
et ensuite tu mets des chevrons
celle ci est faite comme un abat jour
ça c'est des fenêtres que tout le monde
peut faire pas besoin de menuse et
regarde tu les démonte tout seul tu les
lave et tulle et remet
ses de la simplicité mais est-ce que
c'est assez isolé en hiver c'est assez
chaud par exemple
écoute je suis toujours là
tous les gamins de la ville sont venus
ici
bill cowperthwaite a construit sa
première yourte sur le campus de la fac
il a découvert ce style de maison avec
un simple exercice de maths
le cercle est la forme qui utilisent le
moins de matière par rapport à la
surface au sol donc une des plus
économiques
c'est du fil de pêche
oui du costaud 45 kilos avant le sommet
de la yourte arriver là mais je les
surélever pour avoir plus de lumière tu
vois c'est tout le temps en pleine
transformation soyaux alors tu dors là
oui là il ya des rangements
la nouvelle chambre
[Musique]
e
tu vois la plupart des gens pensent que
la civilisation ça veut dire des
toilettes des avions des trains des
ordinateurs mais il n'y a pas de
connexion on peut vivre sans nom
pour moi c'est important d'avoir des
jeunes qui viennent ici qu'ils trouvent
une belle bibliothèque
et une maison sympa à vivre no flash
tout
sans chasse d'eau
sans évier
noël et sans tuyaux
à dénouer en hiver tu viens ici aussi
oui je vis là toute l'année
il ya beaucoup de neige en hiver ici non
il y en a mais pas trop
j'habitais ici au début mais c'est plus
confort sur la colline je veux dire que
tu as construit celle là en premier oui
j'ai commencé par celle ci
là tu vois c'est la douche si tu vas en
prendre une tous les sens et la douche
ok go je vais aller voir c'est la douche
la douche au bord de la mer c'est génial
c'est ton droit
ça fait 48 ans qu'il est à lui quand
même
tous les matériaux pour faire les
yourtes je les ai apporté en canoë oui
oui oui j'ai aussi utilisé un catamaran
bill est docteur en éducation diplômé de
harvard son credo comment vivre
simplement
il organise des séminaires à travers le
monde et vie en vendant les plans de ces
yourtes qu'il conçoit lui-même
[Musique]
tu vois au fond ce qui m'inquiète c'est
qu'on détruise la planète et donc on
doit trouver d'autres moyens de vivre
pas seulement au niveau des
constructions d'ailleurs
oui l'aspect social disons plutôt faire
les choses à la main plutôt qu'avec du
pétrole tu vois une cuillère en bois
comme celle ci j'en ai fait il ya plus
de 30 ans et je les utilise encore
donc tu chasses non fesci pêche non non
non non il n'y a pas assez de poissons
échange je ramasse des moules et des
coquillages
mais je lave jamais mes vitres moins
terrible ne filmez pas ça
[Musique]
chez billy a toujours quelque chose à
faire
bill est un bâtisseur nomades il étudie
un peu partout dans le monde les
systèmes de construction et la beauté
des outils
son plaisir c'est de tout faire de ses
propres mains
[Musique]
les zones la vitesse ok ok c'est bon oui
ça va
stop propos là
c'est vraiment sympa d'avoir quelqu'un
de l'autre côté de l'as si bien
enfin ça dépend qui un
y at il assez d'eau pour les patins 1
je dirais un peu plus
je vais te dire un secret je n'ai jamais
cuisiné de patte de ma vie
quand j'en mange c'est toujours les
autres qui les prépare
tu veux que je m'en charge
bah oui je vais bien
je ne me rappelle plus la quelle est la
poubelle celle-ci celle là ah oui
comme on dit pour poubelles poubelles
poubelle
je n'avais jamais entendu ça on
n'apprend pas ça en cours de français
alors quelle est ta philosophie la
simplicité
oui vivre plus simplement et aussi
essayer de vivre d'une manière juste
pour tout le monde qu'on est dans un
monde tellement injuste
je peux me permettre de te demander ton
âge
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
j'ai 78 78 c'est un mensonge g77 j'aurai
60 18 le mois prochain est ce que tu
peux remporter sa au compost ouais j'ai
vu et
chaque jour tu essayes d'améliorer sa
maison
oui tous les jours tu dois essayer de
faire quelque chose dans ta maison c'est
ma philosophie améliorer la maison tous
les jours à la fin tu as une meilleure
maison
une table multi usages
voilà la asus s'est pas de niveau
c'est une table démocratique tout le
monde peut en avoir une
comme en europe il n'y a pas mal de
temps
attention dessous
il faisait ça à paris au moyen âge
peut-être même il n'y a pas si longtemps
que ça
une minute tranquille
une minute de silence autour de la table
j'avais oublié qu'on était aux états
unis
pour nos petits merci merci
d'un cube est
un plat italien avec des baguettes
chinoises dans un plat danois cuisiné
par un français
alors c'est bon un repas international
[Musique]
en matière d'habitat on trouve de tout
aux états unis pour ce voyage j'ai
décidé de m'intéresser à ce qui dans
l'esprit des premiers pionniers ont
choisi la simplicité et le rapport
étroit avec la nature et les grands
espaces
[Musique]
à 3000 kilomètres de la yourte de bill
j'ai rendez vous avec deux autres
américains qui eux aussi ont choisi de
vivre autrement
[Musique]
alors trembler grandes plaines buts
contre les rocheuses les américains ont
un terrain de jeu fantastique immense
bon là on file vers l'ouest c'est la
ruée vers l'ouest fondateur du mythe
américain
et les américains ils ont gardé cette
habitude de se déplacer il arrive aussi
souvent des grosses caravanes des qui
partent en week-end ils s'installent
dans des coins perdus y sont là un petit
campement on a rendez vous dans un de
ces coins comme ça au fin fond du
colorado
on a quitté l'ohio et l'art et là on
s'enfile dans la
dans la vallée laverie un lac
on devrait bientôt arriver au site d'un
lac
jerry carole et moi on s'est rencontré
sur internet sur un forum de passionnés
de caravanes bien sûr on s'est donné
rendez vous par ici passer un col à près
de 4000 mètres d'altitude j'attends
enfin le campement bon c'est la bonne
piste dans le mans 6e sur des trous
assad m
jerry carole vienne d'al bou kert 600 km
avec leur trailer mythique 1ère stream
[Musique]
tu imaginé un lieu de rendez-vous comme
ça
long voyage non content de vous voir
moi c'est carole enchanté qu'est ce que
tu penses de l'endroit ça c'est un bon
spot bienvenue dans les hauteurs du
colorado
bon ça y est on est chez nous chez nous
ça peut être n'importe où
r c'est une classique
forme
marque mythique ya
la porte avec moustiquaire
c'est un endroit civilisé je vois ça
je sors ça d'abord
mais il y a encore sa tête ça c'est une
vraie deuxième maison o les fleurs au
frigo il y en a encore
c'est incroyable
[Rires]
là il ya un bon couchage certaines
caravanes andelys mais on s'aime alors
on peut dormir dans le même lit de ses
hommes home sweet home
j'aime l'opéra et j'aime les montagnes
je pense que le secret d'une bonne vie
c'est d'être confortable dans les
extrêmes
[Musique]
comme carole et jerry ils sont des
milliers aux états unis à être fan de
ces caravanes construite en aluminium
les trailers airstream sont uniques
elles sont construites comme le fuselage
d'un avion
elles sont uniques
dans les années 60 la marque organise et
même des expéditions à travers le monde
la plus fameuse expédition c'était cape
town le caire qu'etam le caire un
immense voyage je pense que c'était dans
les années 50 aie aie aie ça c'est le
chemin jusqu'au caire
la traversée de l'afrique jusqu'en
egypte
la marque devient une véritable légende
même les cosmonautes en partance pour
l'espace passent leur dernière nuit sur
terre à bord d'une ère stream
[Musique]
dans les années 50 de véritables villes
naissent en plein désert
des campements comme au temps des
chariots cette ville non mais attends
[Musique]
carole hayes jerry continue cette
vieille tradition américaine de
sillonner l'ouest et de s'arrêter en
pleine nature là où la nuit tombée mais
aujourd'hui sans le savoir je me suis
invité à leur anniversaire de mariage
voilà quelqu'un vas-y rentre
on va se régaler
alors tu cuisines pas l'algérie non mais
j'ai la chance d'être marié à une femme
magnifique qui cuisinent djaoui m'a fait
un dîner magnifique quand je les
rencontre et je pensais qu'il fallait
que je fasse quelque chose pour attirer
son attention tu as fait un seul repas
c'est incroyable
ah c'était un dîner superbe je vais les
anniversaires à cherry
à votre anniversaire de mariage
22 ans
encore plein d'autres belles années
comment allez circulez ya rien à voir
[Musique]
c'est pour votre anniversaire
joyeux anniversaire à notre pays merci
jerry c'était bon goût remportait
les chiens mois doré
[Musique]
oh
je reprends la route pour descendre plus
au sud
direction le nouveau mexique à la
recherche d'un autre mythe on est en
route vers drop city c'est une ville des
années 60 70 construite au milieu du
désert est à côté de trinidad est encore
bonne heure de route
drop city dans les années 70 c'était la
ville où il fallait être quand on
voulait vivre autrement tout le monde
m'en a parlé mais pour l'instant c'est
juste un enfer à trouver un sauveteur
large possible
les noms des patelins commence à sonner
latino on m'a dit que c'était du côté
d'el morro
[Musique]
il ya quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
allô bonjour
bonjour comment ça va bien merci et vous
pas mal écoulée je cherche un endroit
qui s'appelle groupe 6 et un drop city
vous connaissez
ouais il reste plus grand chose mais je
peux vous dire où ses pairs
c'était un spotify vous rappeler de
cette époque bien sûr mais vous ne
faisiez pas partie de ces gens là non
j'étais pas hippie moi il y avait des
cheveux longs il était sale enfin je
veux pas dire qu'ils étaient sales mais
il avait les cheveux longs quoi je
faisais pas partie de ça pourtant
j'avais le même âge
ok merci merci à plus
[Musique]
y a pas franchement la tête d'un hippie
mais bon
on cherche drop city c'est par ici
non je ne savais pas s'il ya quelqu'un
d'autre ici ce
nom
brûlant
ok
op cit est ici avait une ville éphémère
il ya des artistes qui avaient construit
des dom en bois et en matériaux de
récupération notamment des capots de
bagnols et c'était là là maintenant je
suis impression qui reste plus rien on
va voir mais
[Musique]
non mais franchement ça disparaît pas
comme ça doit vous qui garde toute heure
ferraille ça traîne dans un coin
quelqu'un à lui recyclé pour faire une
étagère ou c'est pas quelque chose il
reste quelque chose quoi
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous à
collectionner les myosotis
il est magnifique ce tracteur ceci dit
c'est chez mad max banon
à gauche là
en sortant de la voiture c'est pas
sortir
c'est bon
pardon je m'apprêtais à dos petit é
c'était juste en face de l'autre côté de
la route
ça c'était le grand théâtre savez une
forme une taille incroyable
oui c'était solide ce dôme
faute de trouver la ville finalement
c'est à denver que je retrouve le hippie
fondateur de drogue city clark reacher a
perdu quelques cheveux mais pas son
enthousiasme il continue à bidouiller
les dom même s'ils ne sont plus en bois
mais en plastique
c'est l'ombre de la sixième dimension
regarde bien l'ombre
en regardant bien on voit deux diamants
qui se superposent c'est ce style de
forme qu'on utilisait pour les dom
clark a gardé des images de la ville
éphémère
l'histoire de drogue city c'est
l'histoire de trois copains avec clark
en 1965 il achète 450 dollars un terrain
pas loin de trinidad
il commence à assembler des structures
avec des morceaux de bois et du grillage
à poules et l'idée c'est de vivre dans
des dom la forme parfaite pour une
maison
[Musique]
la plupart des gens disaient que vivre
dans un dôme connecté à la terre
on pensait dans les années 60 que ça
étant des le champ de notre conscience
tu ne penses plus comme ça maintenant
ici mais aujourd'hui j'essaye d'être
discret là dessus
le dôme que tu vois là avait deux
niveaux
il y avait une partie commune là et deux
chambres une à chaque niveau
mezzanine oui c'est ça si tu veux savoir
ce genre de maison nous a coûté pour
celle ci par exemple 7 $ 7 $ et quelques
capot de voiture allégeance et bien
oui là c'est celui-là l'actu refait
ouais c'est bien fait ça donne une bonne
idée
[Musique]
assez solide où il y avait trois
familles qui vivaient ensemble
petit à petit la communauté s'agrandit
des architectes viennent de partout voir
ce qui s'invente ici
comme les premiers panneaux solaires
totalement révolutionnaire à l'époque
ça c'est de l'énergie solaire ce sont
des tuyaux non non ce sont des panneaux
de tôle ondulée
là c'était pendant la construction
après on a mis une plaque de verre par
dessus
le métal chauffé les rochers il y avait
deux tu veux dire qu'il n'y avait pas
d'eau juste de l'air non il n'y avait
pas d'eau juste de l'air
ça marchait bien même pendant une nuit
d'hiver très froide il fallait ouvrir
les fenêtres pour refroidir l'intérieur
avec le bouche à oreille en quelques
mois au fur et à mesure que les dom se
construisent drop city devient vite
l'endroit où il faut être
on pensait qu'on avait déménagé dans un
endroit paumé au milieu de nulle part
mais c'est l'endroit le moins perdu où
j'ai habité de toute ma vie
il ya plein de gens qui sont venus le
genre de gars qui sont passés à drop
city c'était timothy leary ou jim
morrison
c'est city c'était plutôt de
l'expérimentation ou de l'utopie tokyo
pour moi c'était plutôt expérimental je
dis souvent c'était vraiment une des
meilleures périodes de ma vie c'était
très excitant parole on pensait à
l'époque tout était possible
[Musique]
aujourd'hui drop city n'existe plus mais
clark et sa bande ont encore quelques
fans dans la région
on m'a parlé d'un certain laine qui
vivraient dans l'un des endroits les
plus perdus du colorado au bout d'une
petite piste dans la vallée de san luis
[Musique]
je débarque à l'improviste dans un
univers en bichromie le blanc et le bleu
[Musique]
ça c'est fait bricolage s'est fait que
de la tôle de récup
des morceaux de verre
bien sûr
lane zone était instituteur depuis qu'il
a pris sa retraite il vit dans ce bout
de désert
vo film et pour halloween non relaxer
juste la télévision française vous savez
des français oui je suis allemand oui
j'ai vu l'inscription là bas
alors tout est fait à la main
oui le solaire les éoliennes tout ça
c'était vraiment nouveau quand je
l'installé
beaucoup de gens disaient que j'étais
fou
vous ne pouvez pas faire de
l'électricité à partir du soleil
maintenant ils ne pensent plus de la
même manière
alors tu vois j'ai été écolo bien avant
beaucoup de monde on peut voir le
domaine bien sûr
ça c'est l'entrée de tout à l'heure ja
oui j'ai appuyé sur la sonnette la barre
et de bergues
beaucoup de choses sont recyclés oui oui
bien sûr ok ça c'est un vieux réservoir
de stations d'essence
ah oui
j'ai doublé les murs avec du béton
parce qu'il ne faudrait pas rester dans
une pièce en métal quand il y à l'orage
et bien sûr c'est ancré très
profondément dans le sol
comment vous appelez ça
est lié à une puce électronique à
l'intérieur rien
chaque fois qu'on pousse l'interrupteur
est ce que tu as juillet tes pieds avant
de rentrer est ce que tu as à refermer
la porte derrière toi si tu as voté
bouche la première fois honte à toi mais
si tu as voté bouche la deuxième fois tu
es trop belle
[Applaudissements]
à ses très radicale ah oui
c'est vrai le tome
[Musique]
j'ai laissé le dôme avec toute sa
hauteur bien sûr
dire qu'il y en a qui font un dôme et
coupe ça en deux pourquoi s'embêter à
construire un dom alors oui
c'est sûr
pensent à une belle cathédrale
est un idiot aurait fait un plancher à
mi-hauteur
et bien sûr la chaleur monte la fumée
mais
là j'ai rempli les murs de mousse
isolante
alors c'est facile à chauffer en hiver
parce qu'il fait très froid en hiver -
20° plus froid que plein d'endroits on
allait
[Musique]
des miroirs des miroirs de partout
pourquoi pas par vanité pas pour passer
son temps à se regarder
pour distribuer la lumière tu vois il ya
des miroirs un peu partout
par exemple si je veux aller aux
toilettes au milieu de la nuit il me
suffit d'éclairer une lampe
et je traverse toute la maison sans
allumer un autre interrupteur
vraiment une maison super
tu es aveugle ou quoi joël est ce que
veut dire
c'est parfait
lane n'a pas lésiné sur l'épaisseur des
murs ils sont doubles avec une triple
épaisseur de métal parce qu'ici au fin
fond du colorado quand on vit dans un
dom même après 20 ans s'est toujours pas
bien vu
ça rend la maison totalement blindés
parce qu'on m'a tiré dessus plusieurs
fois trois fois mais les balles ne sont
jamais rentrés dans la maison
qu'est ce que j'ai fait cette cigarette
c'est fini j'ai dû la mettre quelque
part elle doit brûler sur le plancher
quelque part
[Rires]
[Musique]
je ne peux pas vivre dans une boîte
ordinaire
je ne peux pas rouler dans une voiture
ordinaire je veux que la mienne soit
différent tout concorde à ce que nos
sociétés soit uniforme tout le monde est
supposé s'habiller pareil
manger pareil
et dans quel genre de monde on vit
la plupart des américains vivent
sagement rangés dans des banlieues aux
maisons répliqué à l'infini on construit
n'importe où même en plein désert bref
on surconsomme l'énergie comme si elle
aussi été réplicable à l'infini
[Musique]
on
j'ai rendez vous au nord de taos au
nouveau mexique
ici le rio grande et a creusé un canyon
qui fait plus de 2 100 mètres de
profondeur
un endroit pas forcément très
accueillants où l'on m'a pourtant parlé
d' étrange vaisseau habité on les
appelle les heures chip les vaisseaux en
terre
ça c'est le territoire la banque de
michael renonce c'est un architecte qui
vit ici depuis les années 70 on est à
côté de taos au nouveau mexique c'est
dans le désert et il a monté une
communauté qui est aujourd'hui la plus
grande communauté de maisons en
autosuffisance énergétique avec un
système de récupération d'eau elles sont
incroyables sa mise en rayon il ya des
formes
l'idée de michael c'est de construire
ces vaisseaux avec un maximum de
matériaux de récupération
les murs extérieurs sont faits de pneus
remplis de terre le tout est recouvert
ou mélangé avec de l'adobe un torchis
utilisé dans tout le sud des états unis
[Applaudissements]
l'eau
qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans de la paille
et de la boue du sable et à près de la
terre
et quelle est la proportion ces 2 1
points
et après tu rajoutes la paille
oui on incorpore ensuite
des bouteilles mais aussi des cannettes
en aluminium servent à monter les murs
double avantage on recycle et ça laisse
passer la lumière dans la maison ça
c'est vous
[Musique]
le bâton sert à mesurer l'épaisseur du
mur
tu le tiens comme ça
et tu resteras régulier
de faire ça
ça va
rapprocher
aucune des maisons n'est relié au réseau
électrique
toute l'énergie vient des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes
et puis bien sûr désert oblige l'eau de
pluie récupérée six mois d'autonomie en
eau par exemple pour la maison de ron le
voisin
bien bien c'est un endroit étrange pour
habiter non ouais on s'est installé ici
parce que c'est un des endroits les plus
dures du monde du point de vue de
l'environnement je parle il ya des
changements de climat incroyable ici
on peut voir la maison elle a une drôle
de forme rydzek
à l'intérieur ça fait carrément envie
difficile d'imaginer qu'on est en plein
désert
ça vous avez des salades oui on a
plusieurs sortes de laitue et on fait
pousser des tomates ici et du persil
là on a deux types de poivriers
et puis 1 2 3 4 bananier ils produisent
ouais on fait des récoltes way
c'est tout ce mur est ample exact ouais
c'est un mur de pneus l'ensemble de la
maison est fait avec des pneus recyclés
rempli et entouré de la terre comprend
sur place
c'est pour ça qu'il fait si frais
à cause de l'inertie thermique c'est ça
à l'inertie thermique est impressionnant
voilà comment ça marche c'est simple
grâce à la température constante de la
terre 15 degrés ici et parce qu'on est
relié à l cet air frais pénètre dans la
masse thermique des murs et du sol
alors on était quand il fait très chaud
l'air frais circulent dans la maison et
on va avoir 15 degrés
ce qui est incroyable parce qu'il fait
et 37 degrés à l'extérieur
et l'hiver c'est le contraire il n'y a
pas de cheminée je ne brûle pas de bois
je n'ai pas trop pâle je n'ai pas de gaz
naturel non il n'y a aucun autre moyen
de chauffage que la température
constante de la terre c'est incroyable
j'aime bien ces grandes serres
intérieures après les maisons dans la
nature voici la nature dans les maisons
aujourd'hui rhône construit ses heures
chip partout dans le monde il débarque
chez vous et en quinze jours votre
vaisseau est habitable
alors si ça vous dit
étrange maison respire elles sont
organiques ce sont des organismes
vivants on veut travailler avec la
nature nous nous faisons partie de
l'environnement et on ne peut pas se
battre contre nous ne sommes pas une
boîte carrée posé au sommet de la terre
on veut continuer à être nourries par ce
système global qui malheureusement se
dégrade
c'est tellement simple de comprendre tu
as et comme tu l'as dit en rentrant dans
la maison tout à l'heure c'est différent
de voir une photo et de vivre à
l'intérieur
ici on sent cette terre qui nous
embrasse c'est ce qui s'appelle la
thermodynamique la thermodynamique elle
t'attraper elle te dis et cette maison
va prendre soin de voix t'auras pas ça
dans une maison conventionnelle
non c'est ce que j'appelle
la circulation normale à los angeles
à 1h30 de la circulation infernale de
los angeles j'ai rendez vous avec
michael jones m
michael est un architecte designer qui
s'est mise en tête de faire habiter les
américains ailleurs que dans des
banlieues quadrillée comme des feuilles
de papier
et de les faire vivre un peu dans la
marge
actuelle il a construit si la maison du
futur
maison d'extraterrestres d'ailleurs les
pertes
bon
[Musique]
alors tu t'attendais à ça assez
impressionnant c'est dur d'avoir une
idée quand tu vois ça sur une photo
[Musique]
allons voir à quoi ça ressemble
viennent cette couleur non c'est comme
tâche risque oui il faut que ce soit
assorti
tu aimes ça oui j'aime beaucoup le vert
[Musique]
donc c'est de l'acier du bois chez de
l'acier et du béton un bond du béton oui
c'est du béton composite un mélange de
ciment et de fibres de bois
s'est construit à partir de cubes de
deux mètres cinquante de côté il ya
cette cube qui composaient
mais il pourrait y en avoir beaucoup
plus c'est une structure de départ et
après tu accroches ce que tu veux sous
sorte de panneau
mais pour le toit
oui tu peux créer l'environnement que tu
veux
c'est juste une des combinaisons mais
des milliers sont possibles des milliers
bien sûr tu peux juste continuer à
assembler comme ça et tu peut couvrir la
colline entière si tu veux
michael a tout entendu sur sa maison le
pire comme le meilleur moi j'aime bien
j'ai un peu l'impression d'être quelque
part dans une station spatiale
pour moi c'est la fonction qui doit
créer l'esthétique et le style
parce que de mon point de vu
l'esthétique conventionnelle a tué la
vraie innovation dans l' architecture
particulièrement dans la construction
des maisons
[Musique]
qu'ils dessinent des maisons ou bien les
objets qui les meubles michael est un
infatigable inventeur de formes et des
espaces je n'ai pas tout à fait terminé
je viens juste d'y entreposer mes
modèles
la structure entière fait moins de 300
mètres carrés en comptant les terrasses
c'est petit mais on n'a pas la sensation
d'être coincé
il ya plusieurs terrasses la wii
c'est une chambre j'imagine c'est plutôt
une sorte de salon de lecture
cheminée c'est sympa
oui
plein d'idées
1 2 3 4 5 6 c'est pas alors il ya 18 mur
la wii s'est fait à partir d'un cube
et là tu vois on est à l'intérieur du
cube de s'occupe de deux mètres
cinquante de côté et ensuite j'ai éclaté
le cube
balconnet là il ya un balcon
un petit balcon
oui il suffit juste de déboulonner
quelques panneaux et tu peux tout
recouvrir oui il suffit de retirer ce
boulot-là des deux côtés
et puis après ça se met à blake
s'est remplie de mes modèles c'est ton
travail ou et différentes maquettes
c'est un rocking chair c'est ça avec des
panneaux solaires exact c'est génial
après tu peux y brancher son ordinateur
oui un ordinateur ou un ventilateur par
exemple c'est pour l'extérieur je
l'appelle le rocking relaxe
et là c'est la maquette d'un écho ce pas
là encore tous ces panneaux peuvent être
positionnés des différentes manières on
peut complètement fermée aux autres
choses il y a là des panneaux solaires
et tout ça ce sont des éoliennes un
autre aspect pratique c'est que tu peux
complètement fermé la structure en cas
de tempêtes de sable
des espaces un peu comme dans un bateau
pas immense et bien conçu
encore un peu en avance sur son temps
l'univers de michael commence a
rassemblé dernièrement brad pitt est
venu visiter la maison
finalement c'est un chinois qui l'a
acheté elle sera entièrement démontée
pour être reconstruite pièce par pièce
quelque part en chine
croit que les américains sont prêts à
vivre dans ce genre de maison je veux
dire dans leur tête non la plupart ne
sont pas prêts je pense que le concept
deviendra brancher la plupart des gens
l'acceptent euros je crois que c'est ça
la clé du problème
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de finir ce voyage américain
avec un peu de poésie
c'est l'histoire de nader khalili un
architecte iranien
jusqu'aux années 70 il construit des
tours et des immeubles de bureaux
et puis un jour en voyant son fils joué
dans un bac à sable il a une révélation
et décide de construire sa
des maisons à 500 dollars faite de sacs
plastiques remplis de terre et
solidariser par de simples fils de fer
barbelés
[Musique]
des maisons solides capables de résister
aux tremblements de terre en 2002 les
nations unies font appel à lui pour
bâtir des habitats d'urgence
nader est décédé il ya quelques mois
mais aujourd'hui sa femme il y aune à a
repris son projet
[Musique]
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une toute
petite maison
pour plein de gens ce n'est pas si petit
mais d'un point de vue du standard
américain ainsi
sa combi le contemporain et le
traditionnel
on appelle ça le cocon lunaire j'aime
bien son style
chacune de ces petites niches à
différentes fonctions celle ci c'est la
salle de bain
il ya toujours ce sont incroyables
ah oui ça résonne comme ça à cause de la
forme
le nid pour dormir j'aime ça
je vais essayer mais une petite entrée
mais
ça fait 10 mètres carrés oui ont tous
moins de 30 mètres carrés
au mari disait souvent la terre se
transforme en or dans les mains de
lissage en langue farsi
quand même
qu'il a des usages
c'est l'essence même de ce qu'il voulait
enseigner et que nous essayons de suivre
là c'est ce qu'on appelle le dôme du
poète romy
[Musique]
ici dans le désert tout le monde déteste
le vent qu'il est si fort et si chaud en
été
mais ces petits trous le réguler il
disperse la lumière aussi tu as raison
on sent l'air frais alors on est à
l'extérieur tout en se sentant protégées
actemium en 1990 nader propose à la nasa
de construire des maisons sur la lune
avec une vieille technique iranienne les
cuire comme des poteries situe
concentrent les rayons du soleil tu peux
transformer la serre en céramique
instantanément alors quand il a proposé
cette idée à la nasa de construire sur
la lune ils voulaient utiliser des
grosses gentil le vert pour concentrer
le soleil et produire cette chaleur
comme ça la terre se liquéfie est cool
comme guy magma salut qu'à une sorte de
croo de 5 cm de céramique qui vit de
l'intérieur et tu attends dom
finalement le projet lunaire de nader ne
verra pas le jour mais dans ce petit
bout de désert californien en continue à
construire les maisons qu'il a imaginé
le dernier à s'aventurer c'est bob bryan
bob n'est ni un hippie ni un nostalgique
de drop citytld prof de sociologie il a
juste décidé de quitter la ville et de
revenir à plus de simplicité
je n'avais jamais fait un truc pareil de
toute machine alors tu vois de démarrer
vraiment à partir du sol et monte petit
à petit tout ça a été une véritable
expérience c'était incroyable
depuis deux ans avec ses enfants bob
construit son home sweet home en suivant
à la lettre les principes de nader t
c'est donc là c'est l'entrée principale
oui le bois que tu voies sera enlevé
ensuite
c'est
c'est que de la terre les sacs en
plastique c'est quand même exceptionnel
et un comme technique de construction
très très impressionnant
attention en dessous ok pas de souci
par là il ya l'autre partie de la maison
non ça c'est la chambre non attends je
te monde je ne sais pas encore non on va
voir quand ce sera terminé on va
apprendre à vivre dedans on décidera
alors ce qu'on en fait
une maison à 500 dollars avec vue
imprenable
et pour ce prix là il y à même la clim
c'est ce qui s'appelle le piège avant ça
monte jusqu'au sommet
et tu vois cette sorte d'oreille au
sommet de la maison
oui c pour attraper le vent exactement
oui comme ils font en iran mes enfants
et moi on s'est regardés on s'est dit
est ce que ça va marcher on verra bien
c'est une technique traditionnelle
normalement à la fin de l'année bob et
ses enfants quittent leur petite maison
carrée de banlieue pour aménager soleure
dom
[Musique]
je pense que les dom qui produisent un
effet spécial sur nous c'est dur à
expliquer certaines personnes parlent
d'un sentiment de sacré je ne sais pas
mais il a quelque chose de particulier
juste dans le fait que ce soit un dôme
regarde ça se voit les cathédrales par
exemple tu connais ça mieux que moi
alors je pense que de vivre dans un
endroit pareil produit un sentiment très
particulier
en tout cas c'est ce que je crois
on va te mettre au boulot aujourd'hui
pourquoi pas
je ne sais pas
j'ai un chapeau comme le tien tu sais
c'est vraiment sale nom pour l'adoucir
garde on a des baskets de la même
couleur oui mais ce sont de belles
chaussures
t'inquiète pas que ça c'est très beau
ça ne m'inquiète pas c'est juste de la
terre de la boue
tu t'en sors pas mal parce que ouais tu
trouves
je pense que c'est un expert
il a déjà fait ça avant peut-être
il a de multiples talents
sera le mur français ok oui c'est ça on
va l'appeler le mur français
m
[Musique]
bon voilà j'espère que ce cette
exploration de l'habitat expérimental
vous aura plu vous avez maintenant tout
ce qu'il vous faut pour construire la
maison de renom
bombe à bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures et n'oubliez pas toujours
chercher de nouvelles pistes toujours
sortir des chemins battus halfen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]